hallo zusammen schönen guten Abend
willkommen zu ZDF heute live morgens
Weltfrauentag und wir müssen reden
Ladies und übrigens auch Gentleman es
ist 2023 und Frauen bekommen in
Deutschland für die gleiche Arbeit immer
noch viel zu oft weniger Lohn als ihre
männlichen Kollegen ihre beruflichen
Karrieren geraten oft in stocken wenn
sie Kinder bekommen und im Alter werden
sie häufiger Arm was läuft da schief was
muss ich strukturell ändern was kann
Frau tun was kann man tun darüber wollen
wir jetzt sprechen ihr könnt uns Fragen
posten am besten direkt in die Chats
reinschreiben oder eben an die
E-Mail-Adresse schicken die ihr jetzt
eingeblendet seht wir reden gleich mit
der Soziologin Sarah Speck und mit der
Autorin und Podcast darin Evelyn weigert
die uns aus ihrem Alltag als working mom
berichten wird und jetzt ist sie
hoffentlich auch schon da hallo schönen
guten Abend
guten Abend hallo schön dass sie Zeit
für uns haben ich habe es gerade schon
da erzählt sie haben zwei kleine Mädchen
sie arbeiten als influencerin Podcast
darin Autorin als Malerin wir kriegen
sie das alles auf die Kette
ja manchmal ganz gut und manchmal
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht und merkt dann
dass ich starker meine Grenzen kommen
aber dann trotzdem eine Angst irgendwie
einen Job zu verlieren oder ich bin der
selbstständig
die überwiegt dann so krass dass man
trotzdem durchzieht und eigentlich Dinge
tut die einen am Ende vielleicht sogar
einen Burnout treiben
absolut das ist ein großer Spagat wir
schauen uns mal ein paar Fakten an die
zeigen wie groß immer noch die
Lohnunterschiede zwischen Mann und Frau
sind
Frau und Mann beide haben eine
vergleichbare Tätigkeit Qualifikation
und Erwerbsbiografie trotzdem ist ihr
Stundenlohn im Durchschnitt 7% geringer
tatsächlich sind die Gehaltsunterschiede
in Deutschland noch größer denn Frauen
haben häufiger Berufe und Aufgaben die
schlechter bezahlt werden so bekommen
Männer einen durchschnittlichen
Stundenlohn von
24,36 € Frauen 20 Euro 5 also 18%
weniger zu dieser gender paygap kommt
Frauen arbeiten weniger bezahlte Stunden
im Monat die Schere geht ab Anfang 30
auseinander also dann wenn viele Frauen
ihr erstes Kind bekommen fast zwei
Drittel aller Erwerbstätigen Mütter
arbeiten in Teilzeit aber nur gut 7%
aller Väter weniger Stress bedeutet
Teilzeit nicht Vollzeit Beschäftigte
fühlen sich gesunder Menschen in
Teilzeit fühlen sich häufiger psychisch
belastet t 40% von ihnen klagen über
Termindruck und Zeitmangel vermutlich
durch das Pendeln zwischen Beruf und
Familie
verweigert wenn Sie diese Zahlen sehen
als Mama als Selbstständiger als Frau
erleben Sie die in ihrem Alltag auch und
in ihrem Umfeld
also ich glaube ich kann das nicht ganz
vergleichen weil ich ja selbstständig
bin und kein festes Gehalt bekomme
bekommt das aber mein Freundeskreis mit
das ist diese Ungerechtigkeit einfach
unfassbar groß ist und es macht mich
immer wieder fassungslos dass wir
irgendwie wir können zum Mond fliegen
und wir mittlerweile so schlauen auch
wissenschaftlich so weit und trotzdem da
noch so krass weit zurück und es ist
einfach es gibt überhaupt kein Argument
dafür dass Frauen weniger verdienen also
wirklich gar kein Argument und was ich
damals zum Beispiel total fühle ist halt
schon und das haben bevor ich Mama
geworden bin gar nicht bewusst man hat
einfach zwei Schultern Jobs ja also mein
arbeitet und
holt dann die Kinder aus der Kita ab
oder wenn man noch ganz kleine Kinder
hat ähm von der Oma oder vom eigenen
Mann und arbeitet sofort in der Arbeit
weiter und das ist unheimlich
anstrengend und unheimlich viel
das ist diese Dauerbelastung 257 und die
kann man auf Dauer auch einfach nicht
schaffen Leonie schreibt z.B im Chat wir
Frauen werden wie Menschen zweiter
Klasse behandelt und es ist absolut
nachvollziehbar bei diesen Belastungen
dass sich das manchmal so anfühlt ich
würde jetzt gerne noch Sarah Speck mit
in die Runde holen sie ist Professorin
für Soziologie mit dem Schwerpunkt
Frauen und Geschlechterforschung denn
wir wollen natürlich auch ein bisschen
schauen was passiert denn da guten Abend
Frau Speck
guten Abend Frau zaheli also halten wir
mal fest die Frauen gehen arbeiten sie
verdienen ihr eigenes Geld sie stehen
auf eigenen Beinen und dann bekommen sie
ein Kind und auf einmal wird es wieder
sehr sehr traditionell was passiert denn
da
ja greifen verschiedene Entwicklungen
ineinander aber die Studienlage ist da
sehr eindeutig und zeigt dass es
sozusagen Paare heterosexuelle Paare bis
zu bis zur Geburt des ersten Kindes
oftmals relativ gleichberechtigt sind
auch z.B in der häuslichen
Arbeitsteilung und das nach der Geburt
des er das ersten Kindes und mit jedem
weiteren Kind noch mal mehr bestimmte
wir nennen das
traditionalisierungseffekte Greifen das
heißt dass es zu einer sehr ungleichen
Arbeitsteilung eben kommt sukzessive
mehr das Frauen den Großteil der Haus
und sorgearbeitet
übernehmen und eben auf und Teilzeit
gehen das haben wir ja schon gehört also
das ist zu einer ganz klassischen
Arbeitsteilung oftmals kommt und da drin
aber zu einer sehr ungleichen Belastung
heißt das in letzter Konsequenz ein
Stück weit lügen wir uns vielleicht auch
selber einen in die Tasche und denken
nur dass wir sehr emanzipiert sind sind
es aber in unserem kompletten Leben in
bestimmten Phasen nicht konsequent
ja ich glaube dass die Antwort genau die
Antwort ist ja und zwar in zweifache
Hinsicht also einmal wenn Sie das wir
auf eine individuelle Ebene beziehen
also dann ist es genau so dass in
Biografien ist oftmals so ist dass das
sozusagen für Frauen heute eine selbst
eine Erwerbstätigkeit selbstverständlich
ist und Frauen auch Zugang zu allen
Berufen mehr oder man da gefunden haben
und auch an alle Positionen und auch in
Führungspositionen und wie wir wissen
höchste Regierungsämter und trotzdem
aber die mutterschaftsanforderungen
weiterhin gesellschaftlich noch sehr
traditionelles und sich eben im Bereich
etwa der Arbeitsteilung zu Hause und die
ganze Frage der sorgearbeitet eine ganz
ganz traditionelle Muster weiterhin
zeigen und eben auch in den
individuellen Biografien die zweite
Hinsicht in der das glaube ich zutrifft
was sie sagen dass wir als Gesellschaft
nicht so emanzipiert sind wie wir es
denken oder wie sozusagen das Selbstbild
auch dieser Gesellschaft oft ist oder
auch die Außen Darstellung ist dahin
gehen dass glaube ich Wesentliche
Gedanken Forderungen aus den
feministischen Bewegungen bis heute
nicht umgesetzt sind und das betrifft
zum Beispiel auch eine ganz die
Verankerung der das Verständnisses dass
wir das sorgearbeit und damit meine ich
nicht nur Haus und Erziehungsarbeit etwa
sondern zum Beispiel auch die Pflege die
Betreuung etc also alles Tätigkeiten die
feminisiert sind das heißt von Frauen in
der Regel
durchgeführt werden dass die nicht in
dem Maße anerkannt werden das heißt
finanziell oder auch zeitlich wie es
notwendig wäre in der Hinsicht ist die
Gesellschaft auch noch nicht emanzipiert
und da gibt es auch teilweise Kommentare
wo es in die Richtung geht dass die
Frauen ein Stück weit auch selbst schuld
sind zum Beispiel schreibt scopez wenn
Frauen weniger verdienen nee ich meinte
einen anderen Kommentar wenn man in
Teilzeit arbeitet bekommt man eben
weniger Stundenlohn hat nichts mit Frau
sein zu tun aber Frau Speck jetzt ist es
ja nun mal so dass eben durch die
fehlenden Betreuungsmöglichkeiten etc
einfach sehr sehr viele Frauen eben in
Teilzeit landen
selbstverständlich das ist eine ganz
klassische wir nennen das in der
Soziologie individualisierende Deutung
also die ein gesellschaftliches Problem
einzelnen Entscheidungen zu schreibt
also sozusagen die Frau doch selbst dran
schuld wenn sie sich entscheidet in
Teilzeit zu gehen und nicht weiterhin
Vollzeit zu arbeiten und einmal ist sind
gibt es gar nicht die strukturellen
gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen dass alle
in Vollzeit arbeiten können zu anderen
stellt sich die Frage ob das eigentlich
so wünschenswert ist dass alle in dem
Maße aus in den meisten Maße sozusagen
ja heute heutzutage auch gar nicht nur
40 Stunden sondern auf oft 50 60 70
Stunden tätig sind
erwerbstätig sind und sozusagen die
sorgearbeitet und ich sage noch mal ich
meine damit nicht nur die Betreuung von
kleinen Kindern sondern z.B auch die
Pflege von Angehörigen oder von
Freundschaften etc das was
gesellschaftliche Sorge ist auf der
Strecke bleibt
Frau weigert ich würde sie gerne fragen
sie arbeiten ja auch als influencerin
kriegen sie auch manchmal Kommentare in
die Richtung ab also gibt es Gegenwind
und aus welchen Richtung kommt der dann
haben Sie richtig Gegenwind bekomme ich
nicht aber ich finde eine Sache
unheimlich paradox ich finde man
vergisst auch gerade irgendwie in dieser
ganzen Diskussion dass man ja auch als
Mutter also man hat einen Baby in sich
für 9 Monate man durchlebt die Geburt
ähm man verändert sich ja auch emotional
und ich finde man vergisst auch gerade
so ein bisschen diese diesen emotionalen
Druck den man als Mama auch hat weil ich
glaube natürlich können wir alle weiter
arbeiten aber ich finde manchmal so
komisch dass man auf der anderen Seite
sagt hey du musst wieder anfangen hey
hey mach die immer noch nichts ich suche
das Kind da dann arbeitet man aber
wieder und muss sich irgendwie anhören
ähm
macht jetzt schon wieder irgendwie
Vollgas irgendwie weil man sagt ja auch
immer wieder aus allen Ecken die ersten
drei Jahre sind so unheimlich wichtig
auch für die Kinder dass sie mit einer
festen Bezugspersonen sind eigentlich
für den Eltern und auch auf vergisst
dass der Papa genau so krasser bestand
als Eltern das ist wie die Mutter was
bei uns zu Hause zum Beispiel wirklich
wirklich 50 einfach ganz klar aufgeteilt
ist also mein Mann hat den absolut
gleichen Stellenwert bei meinen Kindern
wie ich
was mich so aufregt ist dieses Gefühl zu
haben als Frau ich habe gar keine Chance
jetzt erstmal vielleicht einfach Mama
sein zu wollen auch und danach irgendwie
wieder einfach rein zu leiden in meinem
Beruf ohne Angst zu haben ich habe jetzt
einen neuen Posten oder ich habe
irgendwie einen großen Verlust das regt
mich persönlich z.B total auf Frau
speckig wird das gerne mal an Sie
weitergeben was sagen da was sagt die
Studienlage ist das tatsächlich für
viele Frauen dann sehr sehr schwer sich
die Freiheit zu nehmen zu sagen ich gehe
in eine Babypause und dann wieder an
ihren alten Platz zurückzukehren
ja das ist ganz klar so dass diese
erwerbspausen in der Regel zu
karriereeinbrüchen führen und das ist
sozusagen eine ein Element was diesen
Gender Pay gab auch erzählt also die
erwerbsbiografieren von Frauen sind
typischerweise andere und haben dann
auch Effekte für das Einkommen und bis
hin zur Rente aber ich finde einen
anderen Punkt noch ganz wichtig den sie
gerade angesprochen haben und das ist
sozusagen nicht nur die
vielfachbelastung unter der Frauen
leiden durch diese verschiedenen
Anforderungen sondern auch die sozusagen
widersprüchlichen gesellschaftlichen
Zuschreibungen also wenn Sie gesagt
haben
das was sie erleben man hat als Frau
oftmals das Gefühl oder ich glaube auch
die Studienlage zeigt dass das viele
Frauen den einen haben was sie tun ist
auch falsch also sind sozusagen
widersprüchlich
im Buch nicht in dem Maße vollzeitig
verfügbar bekommt sie zu schreiben ja
vor allem auf die Familie orientiert zu
sein und als Mutter wird eine entweder
signalisiert man ist nicht genug nicht
genug präsent im häuslichen diesem
Bereich den Kindern gegenüber oder man
arbeitet eben noch nicht Vollzeit also
es sind sozusagen widersprüchliche
Anforderungen als Frauen an Weiblichkeit
heute die gar nicht zu vereinbaren sind
und deshalb auch in ständige
Widersprüche im Alltag führen ja also im
Prinzip dieser Widerspruch hier muss man
doch irgendwann mal brechen weil ich
finde es auch unheimlich unangenehm ich
habe letzte Woche wieder ein Erlebnis
gehabt ich habe mit einer vierfachmutter
gesprochen die auch arbeitet und die
meinte zu mir habe ich mir ein drittes
Kind vorstellen kann und ich meinte ganz
klar wenn es nach mir gehen würde rein
aus meinem Mutterinstinkt und aus meiner
mütterliche Leidenschaft könnte ich mir
zehn Kinder vorstellen aber ich habe
unheimlichen Respekt davor zum Beispiel
von einem dritten Kind weil ich jetzt
einfach gemerkt habe dass mich selbst
das zweite Kind mit dem arbeiten so
einmal die Grenzen gebracht hat und ähm
habt ihr dann erzählt dass ich einfach
durchgearbeitet habe mir gar keine
Elternzeit genommen habe und dann kam
sofort einfach auf den Kommentar ja du
weißt schon aber die ersten Jahre sind
super wichtig mit dem Kind und so und
ich war sofort was glaubst du denn warum
ich so am Ende war weil ich eben beides
gemacht habe also ich habe die Kinder
mit zur Arbeit genommen bin nach Hause
hat mein Mann sofort abgelöst und ich
finde das so schade dass es nicht
irgendwie ein System gibt für uns dass
wir uns irgendwie so ein bisschen
befreien können von diesen ganzen
Presser der da irgendwie auf einem liegt
das heißt die Frauen machen sich dann
auch noch gegenseitig Druck
ich glaube ich finde zum Beispiel
schwierig wenn man sagt Frauen machen
sich untereinander Druck am Ende sind
wir alle Menschen und jeder glaube ich
hat seine eigene individuelle
Einstellung und seine Prinzipien und
glaube ich gerade wenn es auch ums
Eltern sein geht das ist ein sehr sehr
sensibles Thema
wo ich auch im Freundeskreis schon merke
dass man da manchmal fast schon so ein
bisschen aneinander clasht weil der eine
macht so man kann selber Null
nachvollziehen warum das jetzt so machen
wenn man einfach komplett anders macht
fällt
ja ich habe die Frage gerade vergessen
es ging so ein bisschen darum ob er sich
ob es Frauen gibt die sich dann
gegenseitig auch noch das Leben schwer
machen
natürlich irgendwie und ich glaube aber
das ist oft auch gar nicht mal böse
gemeint ist sondern wie gesagt aber
darauf wollte ich hinaus das ist Eltern
sein und Mutter sein das ist sowas
sensibel ist und sowas individuelles und
manchmal vielleicht die andere Seite gar
nicht versteht das ist auch okay ich
finde trotzdem sollte man bevor man was
ausspricht Überlegen Hey warum macht die
Person das so ja vielleicht hat die
gerade keine andere Möglichkeit das geht
manchmal auch um überleben um eine
Existenz und da vielleicht mal ein
bisschen mehr nachzudenken warum
Menschen gewisse Dinge so tun weil das
hat einfach immer einen Grund Frau
weigert bei ihnen ist er jetzt noch mal
eine Sondersituation haben wir vorhin
Vorgespräch festgestellt weil sie ja
weil sich zu Hause die hauptverdienerin
sind
wie ist das bei ihnen können Sie das
vielleicht kurz mal erzählen
also ich bin der Hauptverdiener und also
gerade in der corona-zeit mein Mann ist
Orchestermusiker und die Konzerte
Industrie war ja quasi tot es gab
einfach keine Konzerte und wir haben
genau in dieser Zeit unsere Kinder
bekommen die kam mir aus sehr schnell
aufeinander und ich habe schon gemerkt
dass es mich schon auch das gar nicht
gecheckt am Anfang aber irgendwann dass
ich das so unterbewusst auch schon unter
Druck setzt also dass ich jetzt eine
Mama bin und aber auch der
Hauptverdiener und ähm
ja das ist schon viel und ich wollte
aber halt eigentlich auch so gerne die
ganze Zeit mit den Kindern sein ne also
das kommt ja dann auch noch oben drauf
und ähm ich bin froh dass diese Zeiten
vorbei sind wo ich mit vollen Brüsten
weil ich habe meine Kinder auch gestillt
irgendwo in einem Job fahren musste und
einfach ich mir dachte
ich sterbe und heulen im Zug oder im
Flug
ich will das eigentlich auch gar nicht
aber irgendwie muss ich
und Frau Speck sie haben auch zu diesem
Thema geforscht und sind zu dem Schluss
gekommen dass es ja gar nicht so
unbedingt das ist was viele Männer und
Frauen wollen nämlich dass die Frau die
hauptverdienerin ist in der Familie
das stimmt wir haben eine Forschung
gemacht zu in unterschiedlichen Milieus
zu paarenden heterosexuellen Paaren in
die die Frau das Hotline kommt verdient
und da zeigt sich tatsächlich dass in
vielen Fällen das nicht den
Vorstellungen spricht also das viele
sozusagen traditionellen Vorstellungen
anhängig sind das sozusagen der Mann die
hauptverdienerrolle einnimmt und die
Frau eben Teilzeit arbeitet das aber ist
natürlich auch inzwischen Reihe von
modernen paaren sich als modern
verstehen ein paar Jahren gibt insofern
die sagen sie möchten zugleichen Teilen
erwerbstätig sein und sich die
sorgearbeit Teilen tatsächlich aber wir
haben eben eine qualitative Studien
gemacht die sich sehr genau angeguckt
hat wie musste der Arbeitsteilung
verlaufen und in unserem sample zeigt
sich sehr deutlich dass in allen Fällen
obwohl die Frau nicht in allen Fällen
aber in der Regel obwohl die Frau die
ähm das Haupteinkommen verdient sie
trotzdem noch den Großteil der Haus und
sorgearbeitet übernimmt und eben
meistens auch dass ment
sind ja heutzutage so genannt also
sozusagen die vielen Tätigkeiten im
Blick zu haben die so anfallen um das
die Familie am Laufen zu halten also das
heißt das in der Regel wurde verkündet
wir teilen uns das alles fifty-fifty
aber wenn man sich das genauer angeguckt
hat dann sah das doch etwas anders aus
dazu schreibt Wikileaks ich habe Respekt
vor Frauen sie bekommen die Kinder
machen die kehrarbeit die nehmen nicht
entlohnt wird und bekommen auch noch
weniger Gehalt Frauen sind toll wobei
das natürlich nicht das Ziel sein soll
dass Frauen weniger Gehalt bekommen ich
würde gerne noch mal auf die ähm
Teilzeitarbeit zurückkommen Frau Speck
das heißt ja immer das Teilzeit arbeiten
für Frauen ein Karrierekiller ist aber
ist dieses Denken in den Firmen ist das
denn überhaupt noch zeitgemäß
mittlerweile gibt es Jobsharing Modelle
es wird über die vier Tage Woche
gesprochen wie sehen Sie das
also
jein sind die Antwort wäre ja ein das
ist das Denken zeitgemäß das Denken ist
insofern zeitgemäß weil es glaube ich
die Realität abbildet dass viele Frauen
dafür dass sie in teilzeitabend
drastische Konsequenzen
möglicherweise in Kauf nehmen müssen
etwa auch wenn Beziehungen auseinander
gehen ich sprach schon von Altersarmut
ist das Denken zeitgemäß im Sinne eines
soll es so sein ganz bestimmt nicht also
es gibt inzwischen andere Modelle das
ist auch gut so und ich hatte schon
angedeutet ich glaube es sollte viel
mehr das gesellschaftliche denken sollte
viel mehr dahin gehen dass nicht nur
Frauen überlegen Teilzeit zu machen
sondern dass alle weniger arbeiten unter
weniger Druck arbeiten mit weniger
Existenzängsten Arbeiten verweigert
hatte das gleich zu Beginn angesprochen
das was sozusagen in den Burnout treibt
ist ja oftmals auch die Sorge den Job zu
verlieren also diese Paarung zwischen
häuslichem Druck und sorgearbeitet und
aber existenziellen Sorgen kann ich den
Job weiter ausüben falle ich da raus bei
selbst ändigen insbesonders also die
insbesondere also das heißt diese
Kombination von unsicheren
Lebensverhältnisse und häuslicher
sorgearbeitet die ist natürlich fatal
kommen wir noch mal auf diese Lohnlücke
zwischen Männern und Frauen zurück da
haben wir nämlich ein Beispiel auch noch
mal zu zeigen das ist nicht nur ein
Problem von Müttern schauen wir uns an
eine Magenverkleinerung in der
Adipositas Klinik in Bielefeld ein
Routine Eingriff doch zwei Chirurginnen
im OP das ist auch 2023 noch immer die
Ausnahme
auf eine Chirurginnen kommen laut
Bundesärztekammer mehr als 9 Chirurgen
im OP ist alles ausgelegt auf Männer
das fängt schon damit an dass zum
Beispiel viele OP-Instrumente gar nicht
für kleine Frauenhände gemacht sind oder
dass es sogar ganz häufig so war dass
für mich noch mal eine extra Garnitur
Handschuhe bestellt werden mussten
Ärztin in Vollzeit verdienen im Schnitt
30% weniger als ihre Kollegen die Gründe
sie suchen sich Fachbereiche in denen
weniger Geld zu verdienen ist werden
eher AllgemeinmedizinerInnen als
Radiologin und der Anteil von Chefärztin
liegt nur bei 15%
Medizinerinnen geht es da wie vielen
anderen Frauen entscheidend ist das
Thema Familiengründung und
Karriereplanung können Frauen zu Beginn
des Erwerbslebens Männer inzwischen fast
einholen fallen sie im Schnitt ab dem 30
lebensjahr finanziell zurück Einschnitte
die Frauen bis zur Rente nicht wieder
aufholen
Prospekt wir haben das eben in den
Beitrag gehört da gibt es OP Instrumente
die nicht für Frauenhände gemacht sind
also wenn Sie so wollen gibt es so viele
gaps nicht nur bei der Bezahlung oder ja
da haben sie völlig Recht und da hat der
Beitrag natürlich vollkommen Recht weil
es sozusagen ganz vielen Berufsfeldern
oder natürlich auch in wir kennen das
aus der Gesundheitsforschung wann wird
wird ein weibliche Herzinfarkt erkannt
oder nicht erkannt also es gibt
sozusagen den
mega-geist den männlichen Blick nicht
nur im Kino sondern auch in allen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen wo die Norm
oftmals an dem man orientiert wird
Frau weigert jetzt schreibtchen auf
Youtube ähm die Kitas müssen z.B so
mitarbeiten dass die Frauen ihre
Arbeiten nachgehen können also ganztägig
ist das nach wie vor gerade auch bei
ihnen in Berlin ein großes Problem dass
die Kinder nicht ausreichend betreut
werden können
durchaus ich habe auch unheimlich viele
Freunde die sich wahnsinnig schwer tun
in Kitaplatz zu finden ich habe auch
selber wirklich richtig gekämpft und
musste mich da richtig ins Zeug legen
also um überhaupt einen Kitaplatz zu
bekommen
definitiv aber für mich stellt sich noch
viel mehr auch einfach die Frage wie
kann man das einfach cool lösen dass man
trotzdem auch möglich macht das Eltern
sein auch zu leben und auch für die
Kinder da zu sein und nicht nur einfach
dann schon wieder zur Kita hasseln die
sofort abholen wieder nach Hause ich
habe das Gefühl das ist alles mit so
viel Stress verbunden und ich würde mir
so wünschen dass da so ein bisschen mehr
Leichtigkeit reinkommt und man auch
sagen kann hey ich möchte auch einfach
gerne jetzt mit den Kindern sein gerade
in den ersten paar Jahren und das
einfach möglich ist ohne die ganze Zeit
Angst zu haben dass man irgendwas
verpasst oder vermasselt oder danach
dann irgendwie da steht und nichts mehr
hat also das ist gerade eher so mein
Thema und wie gesagt für viele Leute
weiß ich auch die auch Ärztinnen sind
und so weiter die tun sich unheimlich
schwer mit den Arbeitszeiten das einfach
auch zu koordinieren gerade Leute die im
Gesundheitswesen arbeiten die auch
Schichtdienst haben und so weiter das
ist einfach eine ziemliche
Herausforderung
Elisabeth schreibt zum Beispiel es gibt
auch ab und zu Frauen die mir erzählen
dass sie Kinderbetreuung und alles was
damit zusammenhängt einfach besser
können als Männer und Männer nehmen dann
die bequeme Rolle ein schreibt sie
erleben Sie das auch Frau weigert dass
Mamas irgendwie dann auch vielleicht den
Papas das gar nicht so richtig zutrauen
absolut nicht also wirklich sagen mein
Mann der macht das unfassbar toll ich
habe mich zwar auch ganz am Anfang so
ein bisschen dabei ertappt ich habe
einmal echt so ein Spruch losgelassen
mit mir dachte Alter Emily oldschool
dass du jetzt ich meinte sie so ehrlich
ich finde so krass du bist wie eine
zweite Mama und dann meinte mein Mann so
äh ich bin der Papa Mann also ich meine
das ist eigentlich sollte das ja
gleichgestellt sein und habe auch ganze
das Gefühl gerade so in meinem Dunst
Kreis dass die Papa ist auch eine
unheimlich tragende und wichtige Rolle
in der Erziehung übernehmen und sich da
überhaupt nicht scheuen für
irgendwelchen arbeiten und ich glaube
auch dass wir Frauen uns noch ein
bisschen auch dran gewöhnen müssen dass
der Mann auch einfach großen Teil auf
der Arbeit übernimmt und auch abgeben
müssen und mein Mann der Macht gewisse
Sachen natürlich anders als ich und das
ist aber auch okay ich glaube da muss da
muss ich mich selber auch noch manchmal
sondern eigene Nase packen aber gerade
so in meinem Freundeskreis und meiner
Bubble sag ich jetzt mal das ist
wirklich Gang und Gebe dass ich auch die
Männer wirklich zu 50 Prozent komplett
um die Kinder kümmern und das auch mit
wirklich absoluter Leidenschaft also da
scheint sich tatsächlich was zu tun Frau
Speck ich möchte Ihnen noch was von
Alexander Reichmann Vorlesen der
schreibt uns auf Youtube Frauen sollten
energischer und resoluter auftreten und
sie sollen auch mal auf den Tisch hauen
und zeigen wo der Hammer hängt das ist
aber ja insofern dann wieder
problematisch als das ein solches
Verhalten Frauen ja auch oft negativ
ausgelegt wird weil sie ja dann im
Gegensatz zu Männern zickig wirken
kann sie vollkommen Recht und auch das
ist wieder ein Erklärungsmuster ich
hatte vorhin schon gesagt
individualisierend was sozusagen die
Schuld an der ausbleibenden
Gleichstellung den Frauen gibt und
genauso wie sie sagen
warum können gesellschaftlich also es
geht weiterhin kulturelle Stereotypen
die es Frauen gar nicht leicht macht
einfach so auf den Tisch zu Hause ohne
dass es negative Konsequenzen für sie
hätte insofern glaube ich dass das ähm
nicht unbedingt der Weg ist der leicht
zu beschreiten ist was nicht heißt dass
es nicht auch für Frauen wichtig ist
vielleicht auch ähm erlernte
Zugänge zu verlernen sich anders zu
positionieren auch im öffentlichen Raum
im beruflichen Feld und da auch
sozusagen voneinander untereinander
solidarisch zu lernen und sich zu
stärken gegenseitig
absolut Frau weigert würden wenn sie
jetzt irgendwie drei Punkte aufzählen
wollten die sie bräuchten damit die
Situation sich für die Frauen in
Deutschland verbessert welche würden Sie
nennen
definitiv finde ich muss es einfach eine
Gleichheit bei der Bezahlung geben es
gibt absolut kein Argument dafür Frauen
schlechter zu bezahlen als Männer
dann wünsche ich mir auch dass es
einfach diese Zwiespalt endlich aufhört
und dieses denken dass man irgendwie
entweder nur eine Mama ist oder nur
arbeitet und egal wie man es macht
irgendwie dann ist die so in diesem
Business orientierter Drachen so
ungefähr und die andere ist da die
superklumpe die zu Hause hängt dass man
aufhört die ganze Zeit irgendwie diese
Schubladen zu füllen und ähm der dritte
Punkt
komische Fragen zwei drei komische
Fragen ich kann die Frage auch an Frau
Speck weitergeben und Sie komplettiert
sie dann einfach
wo wo stehen Sie die Frauen stand heute
vielleicht ähm wo würden Sie sagen sehen
Sie eine positive Entwicklung
oh ich sehe ganz viele positive
Entwicklungen zum Beispiel dahingehend
die Art und Weise wie ich hier darüber
sprechen also ich glaube dass ich in den
letzten zwei Dekaden unheimlich viel
getan hat also das sozusagen diese
selbstverständliche Annahme die es gab
Gleichberechtigung ist realisiert und
jetzt gibt es wenn man nur noch
individuell Entscheidungen die ein
Problem sind die ist die hat sich diese
dieses Verständnis hat sich gewandelt
also viele Frauen neben Widersprüche
waren in ihrem Alltag die werden auch in
den Medien etwa thematisiert das ist
glaube ich total wichtig und in der
letzten die Karte in den letzten 10
Jahren gab es global ganz viele neue
feministische Bewegungen vor allem auch
ein globalen Süden aber auch hier der 8
März wieder zu einem ganz wichtigen
Datum geworden wo viele Frauen auf die
Straße gehen wo gestreikt wird morgen
auch in den Kitas etc um auf diese
gesellschaftlichen missverständnisstände
aufmerksam zu machen eben alle betreffen
denn die schlechte Bezahlung von Kita
Erzieherin ist natürlich auch Teil des
Problems also Teil der abgewerteten
sorgearbeitet und ich glaube wie gesagt
gesagt nicht das hat sich glaube ich
angedeutet dass das Problem dadurch
gelöst ist dass alle Frauen einfach in
Vollzeit kommen denn was passiert ist ja
das oftmals sorgearbeit dann einfach
umverteilt wird zwischen Frauen
sorgearbeit wird dann zum Teil
Hausarbeit abgetretener an eine Frau
Putzfrau die vielleicht migrantisch ist
schlecht verdient rassistische
Diskriminierung erleidet eigentlich etwa
eine andere Tätigkeit gerne ausüben
würde oder eben an schlecht bezahlte
kita-erzieherinnen oder so also ich
glaube das sozusagen das Problem viel
umfassender gesellschaftlich gedacht
werden muss und Maßnahmen der
Gleichstellung politisch flankiert
werden müssen von
Arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen von einer Politik
der entpräkarisierung und z.B auch wenn
ich das als letzte Aspekt noch
reinbringen darf
Maßnahmen auf dem Wohnungsmarkt wenn
mieten zugänglich sind bedeutet das für
Frauen die Gewalt erleiden auch
vielleicht da die Wohnung für eine
Wohnung verlassen zu können und sich
selbstständig zu machen zu können also
sozusagen
lebenswerte selbstständig machen zu
können
absolut und ähm sie sprechen das an
dieses Thema ist so wahnsinnig
vielschichtig wir konnten heute nur ein
paar Aspekte davon rauspicken aber wir
halten fest Frauen haben schon sehr sehr
viel erreicht aber es gibt auch
gleichzeitig trotzdem noch sehr sehr
viel zu tun ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen
beiden danke dass Sie Zeit für uns
hatten und sage Tschüss schönen Abend
noch
ja vielen Dank auch euch wir
verabschieden uns fürs erste ZDF heute
live und gehen dann in einer ja ich
würde sagen ca halben Stunde wieder live
und dann geht es um den Anschlag auf die
Pipeline Nord Stream also wenn ihr mögt
bis gleich tschüss